The joe rogan experience.
I was,
I was 22,
and I,
my wife left me,
I moved to Boise just cause it sounded
funny because I was still in that fraud
telemarketing so I could do it anywhere.
There's a phone,
right.
I'm in business.
And then,
uh,
after we moved to Boise and immediately
my wife left me for my best friend.
We all moved out there together and
then my other buddy that moved with us
couldn't handle the stress,
so he went back to Vegas.
So I'm,
oh,
it was all my shit to Boise
and within two weeks I'm alone.
So I moved up to this fucking,
I bought a cabin like a
for sale by owner.
Like,
like I didn't get a loan.
I was like,
I'm just going to give you,
what did he,
what do you call it?
We're
just signed a contract and I'll pay you,
I didn't go through a bank owner financed
owner finance and a little cabin,
two bars in town and you are either a
long branch guy or you're the dirty shame
guy.
And I was a dirty shame saloon guy and
I would drive back and forth cause in a
small town they open around noon
but not necessarily at noon.
And how old were you then?
22 that's hilarious.
No fucking chicks there.
So you were would drive back and forth
in front of the bar until Jolene showed
up to open.
So if it's 1215,
I've been just driving back and forth
waiting for it to open and I would uh,
I lasted like six months and then I had
to ditch out on the fucking there by his
owner financing.
Yeah.
At one point my buddy that moved back
to Vegas came up and he was there for a
couple months,
but we'd get on the phone just
enough to pay our bar tab.
In fact,
my bar tab,
I traded out like furniture when I,
when I bailed,
six months later I traded Jolene like my
furniture in the cabin for my bar tab.
And yeah,
this is fucking crazy.
So you could set your own
hours when you're doing that
scam telemarketing stuff.
He just did it whenever you want it to.
And they just got like you clocked in,
he got pay?
No,
I was doing it out of my cabin.
This was just pick up the phone.
I had leads I stole from Vegas.
And,
and what did you do?
Like how did that work?
I'd call up businesses and the dad the
pitch and you won one of these awards and
you just have to buy this many,
you know,
it was a pens like ad copy,
ad specs,
advertising specialties,
this mug with a,
hey Joe,
uh,
you won a big award and I'm going to,
all you have to do is make a small
purchase of these mugs with your business
name on them,
the Joe Rogan podcast,
and you're guaranteed
to win this big award.
That's worth way,
boy.
Wow.
So it was just a total scam.
Yeah.
Wow.
But cleverly phrased,
so to stay in that gray area of legal,
right,
where like,
I knew a dude who had an
really interesting scam.
He had a scam
where they were making a,
it was a company that would
allow you to fix your credit,
so they would give you a line of credit.
And a,
you would buy things and then pay off
the credit and it would boost your credit
backs.
If you had fucked up credit.
It was all,
it was allowing you to fix your credit.
But the catch was the only things you
could buy with their credit card was
things from their catalog.
So my soul to the company's story,
I,
you know those things.
So they had these Camelot scam,
but I'm catalepsy and words go with stuff.
But say if something costs,
uh,
you know,
whatever it was,
toenail clipper for cost like $3
at the grocery store there is $25.
So if you want to buy it,
you're,
you're giving them a
giant chunk of profit.
So they would ship these terrible little
items and it would really actually
boost these people's credit.
It actually did work wear boot.
So it was enough that,
but it was a total scam.
So you,
you're the only shit they can buy with
your credit cards is stuff from your
catalog and everything's marked
up through the fucking roof.
And this dude made millions
on that made millions
products.
Like when I was working for a
company originally we have the uh,
the uh,
uh,
black matte,
a pen with the gold middle Florentine
Trim and five lines of your ad copy on it
and we'd be selling these fucking
25 cent pens for like $4 a piece.
So it was put the scan that I was just
getting into when I started doing comedy
and then bailed out then went
full time in comedy was the uh,
the invention once like
the George Foreman.
Oh look,
the grill.
Yeah.
Do you have an invention
it and it's a fucking guy.
It's just such a great scam because
egos involved and it's getting,
you know,
everyone thinks they
should be on shark tank,
those kinds of people.
And you go,
I can't say,
but I think what you have here and the,
and then it's a multilevel
where vent help.
There it is.
Submit your invention idea to companies.
I'm not saying invent help is a scam.
I'm saying scams of that.
Do you have an invention?
And then there's step one
is we're going to do a,
like a,
uh,
patent,
research to see,
and this is going to cost you this,
but honestly,
Phil,
I think you're onto something.
I can't say that this is $1 million idea,
but
I know when I have a feeling
it's the way you say it,
but you can look at examples where the
United States has imposed a minimum wage
on other countries.
I mean the minimum wage did a
lot of damage in Puerto Rico.
But you know,
look at another American territory.
American Samoa or in American Samoa.
We basically American Samoa
with our minimum wage.
I mean there's Samoans or you know,
you know,
are,
are furious about it.
This happened years ago actually.
And I,
the reason I even found out about it,
I was watching 60 minutes and they were
doing a report about I think football
players in Samoa.
And um,
and during their report they mentioned
that there was like a depression going on
in Samoa and it was like there was 30%
unemployment and really high inflation.
And I was like,
what the hell is going on in Samoa?
So I wanted to research that on my own.
And I found out that we impose the
minimum wage on Samoa and we destroyed all
their jobs.
They're the two biggest employers were
to a chicken of the sea and starkist,
they were canning tuna and then they
were shipping the tuna back to the
mainland.
But the minute they
raised the minimum wage,
they made the production,
uh,
uncompetitive because now you
had to pay the higher wages,
plus the shipping costs.
They get the tuna back to the mainland.
So they all,
the canneries shut down and then
it created massive unemployment.
And then prices went way up on the
island because they no longer had boats
coming back and forth to pick up the tuna.
So now all of a sudden the shipping
cost of imports went way up.
So they had massive inflation,
sky high unemployment,
all because the minimum wage.
So you could look at examples of
how minimum wage destroys jobs.
Uh,
you know,
right there,
yet they continue to advocate for these
higher wages because it sounds good.
Oh,
everybody should earn a decent living.
Well,
you know,
not,
if you don't have any skills,
you can't.
And a lot of course you
know a lot of kids here,
you know,
they're 16,
17,
18,
19,
20.
I mean people live with
their parents still.
Uh,
the most important thing is getting a job
so you can acquire the skills to get a
better job to,
you know,
to move up the ladder in an
organization to enhance your,
you know,
your value to employers in general.
The argument against this,
short against what you're saying about
minimum wage against to all of these
ideas that you're,
you're just proposing,
do you do get a lot of pushback?
I mean,
I'm sure what you're saying,
this free market capitalism approach is,
you know,
there's a lot of people that oppose it.
Of course.
I mean know there's a lot of
people that don't think it out.
They think with their mind or their,
or their,
their heart and they don't even get there.
The re the origin of the
minimum wage was racism.
I mean,
the first minimum wage is here.
It was designed to keep
employers from hiring.
Uh,
the Chinese are from
hiring blacks because they,
you know,
that that's where the
minimum wage came from,
you know,
to try to prevent employers
from hiring certain people.
So they said,
well,
let's have a minimum wage and that will
reduce a hiring of people who have less
skills.
And,
and so,
and the labor unions,
the biggest supporters of the
minimum wage are the labor unions.
And none of the labor unions
workers earn the minimum wage.
So you might think,
why are they,
did they still care
about the minimum wage?
If they don't,
they'll get paid a lot
higher than minimum wage.
And it's because you always have a
competition between skilled labor and
unskilled labor,
right?
So let's say a business,
a business man has the option of hiring
a skilled person to do something.
And let's say the skilled person is
going to charge quite hours an hour or an
unskilled person.
And let's say I can hire three
on skilled people for $5 an hour,
and that equals 15.
Well,
Hey,
I'd rather hire the unskilled worker.
I can pay three $5 an hour to do
the same job of one skilled worker.
But now if the skilled worker can,
could lobby for $7 minimum wage,
now if I have to hire
three unskilled people,
it costs $21 Aha.
Now all of a sudden,
I hire the guy with skills.
So the labor unions benefit by keeping
unskilled people unemployed because they
have more skills and therefore they can,
you know,
they can get more work.
That sounds like a complicated mess to me.
It is a mess for the,
for the,
for the people that get
get priced out of a job.
Yeah.
Okay.